frustrante parce qu'on nous répète les
mêmes éléments de langage et qui sont
invraisemblables
on est dans le déni on nous explique que
monsieur benalla ne s'occupait pas de
questions de sécurité alors que tout
montre le contraire à la fois les images
des visuels et les écrits l'arrêté du
préfet de police ce qui lui accorde le
port d'armes
son cv le chef de cabinet qui me dit
d'avoir recruté avait devant lui
forcément un cv qui n'avait comme
expérience peyrens que la sécurité et
nous dit qu'il avait recruté pour autre
chose quoi tout est invraisemblable
on nous mène en bateau vous des normes
incohérence avec ce que maintient
l'elysée à savoir que alexandre bédat là
n'avaient que des fonctions
organisationnel mais bien sûr c'est
complètement incohérent c'est
invraisemblable ces démentis non
seulement par les images par des
documents administratifs et par les
déclarations même de monsieur benalla
sur tf1 fin juillet donc ça ne tient pas
alors pourquoi veux tu on nous le
dissimuler ce serait pas plus grave
c'est effectivement été chargé de la
sécurité puis qu'à un moment il est
débordé qu'il ait été sanctionné quoi
pourquoi veux tu ont dissimulé sa suit
votre raisonnement on s'interroge pour
les raisons pour laquelle l'elysée ne
veut pas avouer cette fonction
d'alexandre benalla pour vous c'est
parce que il y à un dysfonctionnement
parce que effectivement la sécurité du
président de la république normalement
ne ressort que du commandement militaire
et du gspr à l'évidence il ya un
dysfonctionnement sur it et du président
de république avec d'autres incohérences
on nous explique qu'il n'avait pas l'âme
d'un déplacement public mais dans les
déplacements privés et en même temps que
le j'espère le protège et 24 heures sur
24 165 jours par an c'est dire aussi
dans les déplacements privés
c'est une autre invraisemblances donc il
n'y a que des invraisemblances ce que
pour vous et alexandre benalla par sa
proximité avec le président de la
république a eu une fonction qu'il
n'aurait pas dû avoir au sein du palais
l'elysée
c'est évident nous explique même que
c'était qu'un jeune de 27 ans pouvait
lui pardonner c'est vrai qu'il avait
beaucoup de qualités et les défauts de
ses qualités
mais est-ce qu'à 27 ans on peut tabassé
des manifestants dans la rue et sk 27 on
peut en même temps être chef adjoint
du cabinet d'analysé demi surveillants
fonctions d'adjoint au chef de cabinet
et en donnant des ordres aux geo
généraux aux officiers supérieurs
puisque c'est ce que nous ont dit les
syndicats de policiers même si ces
démentis par l'elysée mais en même temps
benallal lui même nous dit sur tf1 je
faisais chier tout le monde
donc voilà c'est complètement incohérent